à berlin la politique à coups de
concerts les autorités de berlin est
avait organisé hier soir un grand
concert rock animé par la star du
patinage katarina vite pour empêcher que
la jeunesse est allemande a et tendre
l'oreille près du mur pour entendre
michael jackson qui était de l'autre
côté côté ouest eh bien c'est raté
la manoeuvre de diversion a échoué et la
police a dû intervenir
elle a même empêché certains
journalistes faire leur travail en
brutalisant plusieurs équipes de
télévision certains jeunes disaient
qu'ils étaient venus plus pour protester
contre le mur que pour écouter michael
jackson enquête philippe rochot en
allemagne 50 arrestations devant la
porte de brandebourg à berlin est deux
policiers blessés
les deux correspondants des chaînes de
télévision allemandes agressé par des
policiers infiltrés parmi les jeunes
c'est le bilan du week-end de rock le
plus choqué connu berlin depuis l'an
passé
ces incidents avaient une signification
plus que politique
c'était la fête nationale en allemagne
fédérale le jour de l'unité allemande
qui commémore les émeutes ouvrières de
53 réprimée par les chars soviétiques
dans la concurrence que se livrent les
deux allemagnes en matière de rock
l'allemagne de l'est ne fait pas le
poids face à michael jackson et au pink
floyd la rda n'a pu opposer que la
patineuse katarina vite
james brown et un groupe canadien
inconnu voilà pourquoi les jeunes de
berlin-est se sont tournés une nouvelle
fois vers l'ouest pour le concert de
michael jackson occasion de crier leur
colère contre le mur de berlin comme il
l'avait fait en juin dernier après le
concert que david bowie donnait à berlin
ouest et où 70 personnes avaient été
arrêtées
l'allemagne de l'est c'est qu'elle a
beaucoup à perdre dans la bataille du
rock
les jeunesses communistes organise
pourtant des concerts pour empêcher des
moins de 20 ans de se tourner vers
l'ouest mais michael jackson ne vient
pas encore chanté de l'autre côté du mur
la glace nost n'a pas encore ouvert à
ces jeunes d'allemagne de l'est
les portes des fantastiques concert de
rock qui se déroule chaque année à
l'ouest